just recently a new deal has come to
light and if everything goes according
to plan it might just change the way we
interact with the internet completely
because as it turns out in may of this
year spacex elon's company which is
famous for well going to space has also
been slowly building up an internet
satellite network and signed a deal with
none other than the tech god google this
historical deal not only makes the
future elon envisions more likely but
will also directly affect each of our
individual lives if there's one thing
that you can expect elon musk to do it's
to make decisions that won't only
benefit him as a businessman but ones
that can legitimately impact the way the
world works one of the ways he does this
is by opening partnerships that will
benefit the public be it allowing other
electric cars to charge at their
superchargers or literally working with
china to make electric vehicles a norm
there it seems there's nothing that elon
can't do with the right partner so let's
take a look at some of the things that
the deal is related to and how they'll
impact you the deal now looking at the
objectives of both of these companies
starlink trying to become the world's
biggest and most robust internet network
and google trying to make their cloud
network more widely available and well
just plain bigger it's not a surprise
that both jumped at the opportunity to
join forces for this endeavor as bikash
kohli google's head of global networking
would say the power of combining cloud
with universal secure connectivity it's
a very powerful combination this goes to
show that combining the world's largest
network with the fastest growing cloud
on that network is a move that benefits
both the ceo of the google cloud group
thomas curion has said that spacex chose
them because of the quality of our
network and the distribution and reach
of our network and then there are the
company histories because as it turns
out this is not the first time google
and spacex have interacted since in 2015
google invested 900 million dollars into
the space company to cover an array of
technology including starlink satellite
manufacturing and so with all of that on
the table i don't think it's a surprise
that they're collaborating if that's not
convincing enough we have the next major
point the competition by far the most
active reason for the companies joining
together has to be their common threat
because as they say the enemy of my
enemy is my friend and google and spacex
face one of the strongest common enemies
there is amazon
[Laughter]
from the fact that amazon is the literal
founder of the cloud processing industry
with a launch in 2006 of general-purpose
computing and storage tools from its
amazon web services division with google
coming onto the scene with its own
computing service all the way later in
2012 and while you guys may already be
familiar with blue origin jeff bezos's
answer to musk's spacex that's not the
only place the tech giants go toe-to-toe
the far more terrifying prospect is the
kuiper project from bezos's amazon which
aims to launch well over 3000 satellites
in roughly the same orbit as starlink
for the exact same purpose to become the
sole source of the world's largest isp
network with amazon web services still
being way ahead of google in raw usage
and kuiper having enough backing to make
elon reconsider his choices the only
logical outcome for the companies was to
join forces what is starlink with the ev
world and the new space race both moving
almost as fast as the cars and rockets
that involve them it's hard to keep
track of everything elon musk is doing
one moment he's out drilling holes in
the earth to make supersonic trains
while another he's planning to fly
millionaires to space so it's easy to
miss this tiny subsection of just one of
his companies but don't be fooled guys
because although everything he does will
impact everyone eventually starlink
might just be on the doorstep of the
entire world population in a few years
because that's exactly what the plan is
for this company to provide quality high
speed clean internet at an affordable
cost to every single location on this
planet and all of that without having to
lay a single optical or other cable to
anyone's home before you brush this off
as something that's going to happen in
the far future don't be fooled as the
company has already launched
1625 satellites in space with
1550 already in functional orbit if you
haven't guessed already that's how the
company hopes to accomplish this future
by sending thousands of these satellites
into space to create a blanket of the
internet over the entire surface of the
earth although satellite tv and stuff
like that is nothing new those things
are generally extremely slow and need
ridiculously complicated equipment to do
something as simple as watching one
stream of video it's for that reason
that the internet is almost always
provided using massive cable networks
underground and under the sea that is
until now with spacex's robust
experience in orbit and elon's other
companies all providing valuable r d
it's only a matter of a few years before
that internet is available to literally
anyone who lives under the sky with
plans to sell small portable dish
antennas that can connect to satellites
in the remotest of locations from a
campsite in the amazon to a jeep roof in
the sahara this technology will affect
the future and day-to-day lives of
billions of people and hell if you want
to know just how fast that future is
approaching the starlink beta has
already been up and running since last
year and has amassed a huge 10 000 users
across the us canada and a few european
countries with at least 500 000 deposits
of 100 placed by potential customers of
the service now that's enough about
starlink the next thing that we should
talk about is of course google cloud the
unseen background world now while
starlink is all glamour and shine the
google cloud is something you'll rarely
actually interact with while knowing
that you're doing so and the reason for
that is well you've already interacted
with it every day you've been on the
internet from your expected google
applications like gmail and youtube to
thousands of websites all across the
internet that all use google's pre-built
servers and connections to run it's not
an overstatement to say that google
cloud is practically everywhere from
giving small websites access to stuff
like google play adsense plugins and
card payments to more basic stuff like
storage communication and computing the
cloud is the backbone of a ton of things
that millions of users rely on daily as
a result it's no surprise that while you
and i know google for stuff like chrome
search and youtube their cloud service
is slowly becoming the backbone of their
business with them slowly moving towards
strengthening this side of things in
fact investors are already betting on
the cloud to become google's biggest
hustle because although they still rely
on ads right now in the future stuff is
about to change judging from the fact
that while the cloud business delivered
only seven percent of the company's
revenue in the first quarter it grew
almost 46
year-over-year compared with growth of
32 for google's advertising services
other partners you see before the google
deal became official spacex had already
started to get its foothold in getting
cloud computing partners in the form of
none other than microsoft and their
network named azure which became a
partner of spacex all the way back in
october although they are smaller than
both google and amazon azure is still a
major player in microsoft's windows and
office side of things not to mention
that getting such a big partner to team
up with you is always going to be a good
thing according to a microsoft
spokesperson who wrote to cnbc their
partnership with starling provides
high-speed low-latency satellite
broadband and will extend their
capabilities with worldwide satellite
connectivity and unblock cloud computing
in more scenarios what all of this means
is that starlink is not only trying to
become big as a simple isp but is
already gathering support from the
internet's biggest players effectively
guaranteeing the success of their
eventual goal and that finally brings us
to the future of the internet all of
that sounds nice and good but what
exactly does this deal signify other
than just another mishmash of corporate
mumbo jumbo well as it turns out quite a
lot first off it marks spacex one of the
world's biggest privately held companies
having raised money at a 74 billion
valuation in february as the prime
choice of one of the world's absolute
giants in the tech and internet
industries effectively making the future
fall snugly into their hands more
specifically though as said by a
statement from gwen shotwell president
and chief operating officer of spacex
combining starlink's high-speed
low-latency broadband with google's
infrastructure and capabilities provides
global organizations with the secure and
fast connection that modern
organizations expect she went on to say
that they are proud to work with google
to deliver this access to businesses
public sector organizations and many
other groups operating around the world
and that's about it with a simple
aligning of interests these two
companies from entirely different worlds
are moving toward becoming one of the
biggest factors in what shapes the
internet as well as our future and that
brings us to the end of our video i
really hope you enjoyed watching it if
you did be sure to leave a like down
below and subscribe if you want to see
more